[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Alexandra
how can we help
today hi I'm so glad to talk to you you
guys are my favorite Duo on the Ramy
show what Alexandra you're our favorite
caller love you guys so much George
you're so funny and Ken you always give
the best
advice thank you so my question today is
I recently got a second job and it is to
help
basically save up for my mov to Idaho
and I met my boss at least a week ago
over the weekend and she hasn't seem
like she's really the nicest person
she's very rude um when I first met her
we went um to do some training and she
got upset that I had brought a packed to
lunch with me to work um and then
yesterday she called me and because I've
been asking so many questions because
I'm new to the place um um and I haven't
really gotten the proper training that
I've been asking questions and she
called me Annoying for asking her
questions regarding my job and I just
don't really know how to handle a person
like that who is angry all the time yeah
and how long you've been in this
job it's been two weeks o and you're
thinking about moving to Idaho for this
I'm thinking about move yeah I've been
planning to move to Idaho since the
spring earlier this year okay um just
because in California it's getting out
of control the
connection so here here's why I'm asking
here's why I'm asking the Idaho question
so you want to move to Idaho whether
this job is is this a remote job
anyway um no it is in person so you've
already made the move to
Idaho I have not so this is in the San
Jose area I'm so confused okay okay so
so I'm planning to move to Idaho and I
got this job so that I can save up money
oh I see so this is your second job and
you have the rude boss at the second
job yes oh okay this is temporary all
right I'm trying to get to the bottom of
because here here's why I'm asking all
the questions
okay this isn't worth putting up with
she's not going to change this is a
woman who got upset with you because you
brought a packed lunch how dare you who
gets irritated over somebody packing
their
lunch yeah she seems like the type of
person who gets very triggered by people
who just live a different lifestyle than
she does uh yes and and this is America
you know you can you know you have
absolutely lunch was a lifestyle it's
not she's just unhappy and she's looking
for anything possible to be rude about
cuz she's very
unhappy can I ask what kind of job this
is this is a sales job it's a um it's a
company based in South Korea where um
it's a wellness company that sells um
thermal massage beds um that look like
furniture and so we are we cater mostly
to people who have back problems or for
people who work all all day lift howy
things um it sounds delightful I would
love this product problems I would love
this product but this is just a second
job for you so how much are you making
in this second job is it hourly or is it
commission it's both so I make
40K is my yearly income and on top of
that I make 300 per unit I sell okay
$300 per unit I sell I think you have
two options one you just put up with her
nonsense you know and just put up with
it because it's a second job and it's a
means to an end it's literally I'm
trying to bank money so that I can check
out of California and move to Idaho so
you either just decide can I put up with
her rudess and move on and make good
money and just deal with her whatever
she is is or the other option is to go
if I can't deal with it then I got to
move on and I'll go find me another
second job that I can make the same
amount of money and not deal with all
her crap those are your two options
she's not going to
change yeah and I realized that so which
is the bigger Hass thing is that she
basically so my my main income I work
for my mother she's been abstract um
artist and she has her own business and
so I handle like all of her social media
um and I also assist her at some of her
workshops too that she does Across the
Nation
okay and that's $20 an hour um and it
can be it's it's part-time and then the
other one
is it is also part-time um so I work
five days a week for my mom and I
usually work early in the morning and
then um I basically work at my other job
from 10:30 a.m. to
7 PM so it's about an eight and a half
hour shift but that's irrelevant depends
on how much they schedule it's
irrelevant the question is which is the
bigger nuisance for you dealing with the
rude boss who's clearly hurting and she
her life sucks in some
way uh or moving on to uh a different
part-time job which is the bigger
nuisance or you just say I'm not going
to work for Mom I'm not going to work
for a rude person and I'm going to go
get a full-time job that pays me really
well so I can St back up cash and move
to Idaho you have three options which is
the
least of a
nuisance because these are all
short-term
plays yeah so which
one well I definitely want to um work in
customer service as a full-time job and
I've been applying to places like that
um and for some reason I'm not getting
any well that's okay you just got to
stay with it but I mean I here's what I
want to do I want to answer your
question why you
called and and so you're not going to
change this lady you're not going to
change
her so yeah you you have the option to
deal with it and keep stacking the cash
that comes with it and go this is just a
shortterm play or you move on to another
short-term play you have to decide but
you don't have to leave you could put up
with her long enough to replace that job
work around
her asking can you
yeah I mean I think I want to stay with
the company just because it is still new
and I
do income to keep then who cares what
she says about your pack lunch and who
cares if she calls you annoying you know
get the answers you need to do the job
well yeah well I the thing is is that I
never really have to see her in person
she just calls me because she lives in
Los Angeles great even better she's the
regional she's the regional manager and
I'm the supervisor of the store great um
so I report to her on the basis of you
know the day that I well she can't see
any more of your packed lunches so that
problem is solved that's true there we
go one problem solved I would just put
your head down and do your job and don't
worry about her but sorry going through
that that's never fun and uh hopefully
gives you more fuel to make this move to
Idaho and and follow your dream and get
a great customer service job and all of
that create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life